welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of
invincible season 2 episode 3 titled
this missive this mination a title taken
from the crazy voiceover structural
device of this episode this episode
being a chapter that really misdirects
us into thinking that we can escape our
demons but really those demons are
always there to beckon us back down
let's break down this episode for all
the Easter eggs animation details and
deeper layers of meaning that you might
have missed and click the link in the
description box to download Dragon air
check out the exclusive gift codes to
Redeem limited option gift packs join D
and D Legends in dragon air so we open
with Debbie dropping off Mark for his
first day of college at Upstate U she
tells him that this is his chance to
figure out who Mark Grayson really is
for most empty nesters dropping their
kid off at college that would be
emotional enough but imagine Debbie she
now has no one to rely on who
understands her pain to help her process
her grief even sadly we see this episode
therapy doesn't work for her now I said
this last episode but I think the bond
that Debbie and Mark share is what sets
this universe's Mark apart from the
others who sided with omn man like maybe
in other dimensions Debbie's not around
or she Di and wasn't there to guide Mark
when he was growing up this is an
episode all about relationships and it
opens and closes with the two most
formative ones for Mark Debbie adds one
last bit of advice that Mark not do
drugs and he asks if they would even
work on him later on when Mark and Amber
have sex for the first time she asks him
if he has super sperm or if he'll Crush
her while they're doing the deed I love
that the show asks all these meta
superhero questions that we always
debate with our friends we've seen
Heroes like the flash or Claire Bennett
from the show Heroes be unable to get
drunk because their metabolism or
superhero healing powers was also a
debate had on She-Hulk with Jennifer
Walters and Bruce Banner having to drink
so much at that Tiki Bar and asking if
Captain America could get drunk so
there's a good chance that drugs will
not have an effect on Mark but we will
see if an immunity to drugs and other
kinds of toxins is something that seil
tests on him in her car Debbie wipes
away tears and takes out that card that
Olga gave her last episode it has three
dots three dashes and then three dots on
the front which is Morse code for
SOS and on the back it has this phone
number 18005550199 which is a fake
number that's used in a lot of shows and
movies like Rick and Morty Spider-Man 3
and Tim and Eric awesome show fun fact
the phone number that begins with 555
isn't always a fake number it only goes
up to a certain range for the last four
numbers so Debbie calls this number and
a woman answers who insists that they
don't use last names only first names
later we find out that this is because
it's a phone number for support group
for spouses of superheroes run by this
woman on the phone Carol voiced by Leah
Thompson I do find it interesting that
she was so distracted at the beginning
of the phone call later she says it's
because she has like a newborn but I
wonder if there's something else going
on there Mark's rooming with his best
friend who's worried that Mark's Seance
dog poster and box of toys are too
childish and will hurt it game Seance
dog is Mark's favorite comic changed
from science dog in the Invincible
Comics because of Rights issues it's
about a Jack Russell Terrier who's a
master at the metaphysical arts and yeah
he's pretty much like a dog version of
Doctor Strange on Will's side of the
room perfectly placed there's framed
posters of Magnum PI which is a play on
Magnum PI with Tom celic the original
Magnum PI and a signature Hawaiian shirt
and then DTF which is probably a take on
BTS and Lil BOS X and instead of Lil nzx
and this looks like a parody of his
Montero album cover and Lady Yaya a take
on Lady Gaga there's also a lovely throw
rug hotted plants succulents and this
has to be the best decorated dorm room
in all of history Marx's box of toys oh
sorry Collectibles includes a seance dog
action figure some robots a giant
eyeball creature that kind of looks like
the beholder from Futurama and this army
man who looks like beach head from GI
Joe but is probably just a generic green
army guy Market self-conscious and
throws this box away but goes back for
Seance dog because that's his favorite
it's kind of like Woody from Toy Story
those poor other toys if they are
sentient in Amber's dorm room she has a
big X poster on her wall and a poster of
a man singing which looks like an homage
to Nat King Cole Amber and Mark decide
to have sex for the first time and Mark
gets caught in a sweatshirt and she
kisses him with half his face covered
kind of like Mary Jane kissing
Spider-Man in the rain so here the
episode does something amazing it
transitions from this to a narrator's
voice the voice of Paul F Tomkins doing
a parody of old 1930s and 40s sci-fi
radio shows like Bas of Flash Gordon and
and so dear audience perhaps it's time
to give Amber and Mark some privacy and
turn our attention to the stars and a
story that began Generations ago in this
missive this mination the narrator gives
the backstory of Alan the alien who we
met in season one voiced by Seth Rogan
it expands on what Allan told Invincible
about the vites destroying his Planet
yopa as in no the yopin were peaceful
and highly Advanced before the vites
attacked we see a younger omn man taking
part in the destruction specifically he
seems to be partnered with one other
female Vite and I wonder if we'll get
her backstory at some point the yopin
blast at the vites purple energy that
kind of looks like the beam that the
heroes tried to hit omn man with in the
premiere in that alternate universe the
unopen rebelled and were defeated omn
man rips this one's arms off leaving
just ahead on the ground looking kind of
like Mark's oneeyed creature toy from
earlier one ship of yopin escaped kind
of like baby Cella escaping Krypton
before it was destroyed the unopen
survivors started breeding camps to
replenish their population and make
yopin of enhanced strength to stand
against the vites this caught the
attention of fetus leader of the
Coalition of planets who offered to let
them join their ranks the Vite campaign
has become the scourge of the Galaxy yes
that is legendary voice actor Peter
Cullen as thus Cullen is the voice of
Optimus Prime from Transformers eore
from Winnie the Pooh and a bunch of
other stuff in an interview Invincible
Creator Robert Kirkman said working with
Cullen was a test of his professionalism
because he was such a big fan of his
Kirkman said quote to say there were
tears is embarrassing but whatever I'll
say it Optimus Prime big part of my life
you know I've been hearing Peter
Cullen's voice since I was like 7 years
old the narrator goes on to explain that
Allan was the only successful unopen
experiment but while he was strong he
wasn't strong enough to stand against a
Vite in combat the program was deemed a
failure and instead Allan was made a
planetary evaluation officer sent from
planted plant def find fighters who
could defeat him and maybe help defeat
the vites we get a play on the usual
Invincible title because sometimes to
change the entire universe you have to
be yeah instead slam counting into
Allen's logo and then Allan heads back
to the planet Testa after mission and
gives these plugged in Aliens his data
log they rib him a little about how he
was able to find the right Planet this
time in season 1 we learned that Allen
had confused Earth for uro and had been
monitoring the wrong one for years
General tella tells them that the vites
took over the planet acrion while he was
away they had recently joined the
Coalition of planets which has caused
all the other planets who were thinking
of joining to cut off Communications out
of fear thus asks Allan what news he
brings and sitting to his left is a
human lion who seems to be the same
species as battle Beast who we saw in
season 1 Allan tells them all about Mark
being Invincible half Vite and that he
an omn Man fought causing nnim man to
leave Earth Vite against
Vite that has not happened since the
Great Purge the Great Purge was the Vite
Civil War that omn man told Mark about
in season 1 everyone on the planet went
to war with one another to weed out
those deemed weak thus pulls Allan aside
to tell him he thinks there's a mole
inside the Coalition feeding info to the
vure and Allan offers to find out who it
is he flies back to his house where he's
greeted by his adorable alien catlike
creature who has two buttholes instead
of one and I like how they just display
it with x's and apparently that's okay
to show but not two bipeds having sex
and we find out that Allan and general
tella are dating and the narrator gets
squeamish as Telly as tentacles come out
for some alien sex and he shifts his
Focus back to Mark and Amber who are
also still going at it so he tries to
focus back to Allen's cat thing who
promptly starts licking it booty holes
it's a great bit Paul of Tomkins plays
it perfectly and wait are they both
booty holes or are they like a booty
hole and another hole I'm overthinking
it Allan and tella go on a date and he
eats these terrified looking worm thing
served to him by a waitress who looks
like a humanoid chicken as some of the
worms try to flee the bowl Allan shovels
the rest into his mouth and tella says
she doesn't know how he can eat those we
see that she is eating the brain of a
creature who is still alive and stuffing
the escaping worms into its own mouth if
you're a fan of fantasy then you already
know how well that genre works as a game
you get to be the one exploring fighting
questing it's the best and one of the
best fantasy experiences you can get
right now is from dragon air silent Gods
Dragon Aire silent Gods is an open world
strategy RPG inspired by Dungeons and
Dragons with over 10 million downloads
worldwide no wonder dragon air has
secured the top spot in more than 10
regions since its Global launch and now
dragon air silent Gods is introducing
iconic Dungeons and Dragons characters
like drizin and U to the game on
November 17th and we'll have more iconic
characters coming in upcoming seasonal
releases trz in his black Panther gavar
will have a complete storyline for you
to play through as well as plenty of
open world exploration enemies to fight
and treasure to find dragon air is now
live on Windows Mac Steam and epic with
compatibility on Android and iOS click
the link in the description to download
Dragon air today and use these gift
codes to Redeem limited option gift
packs Allan tells tiia that thetus
thinks there's a mole but before we can
give her any details before we get to
even see her reaction to that he's
dragged out to open space by a group of
fites who proceed to absolutely kick his
ass when he won't give them any info on
invincible and omn man tella watches in
horror as they take turns beating him
and it's all set to this ethereal
meditation Style music which makes it
even more
[Music]
horrible at one point one of the vmes
rips Allen's arm off and beats him with
it so we see where omn man gets his
fighting style from it turns out Allan
isn't dead which is insane because we
saw a woman literally punch through his
stomach Theta stops by his hospital room
under the pretense of checking on him
and that's when we find out that he
might be the mole in the but he shuts
off Allen's life support system and says
forgive me Allan can't wait to see more
of this character and find out what his
deal is it's worth noting that the
narrator wasn't around for any this part
he seems to have tapped out after the
sex scenes with a STK contrast between
the campy style of the beginning of
Allen story and the Bloody loneliness at
the end of it but I still think the fact
that we cut away from General telia so
abruptly makes me wonder if she might
have been the mole I still could go
either way and maybe he killed Allan
just to like spare him some greater pain
or he has some other plans with Allan
and now again insanely from a structural
standpoint the credits start to roll as
if that part of the episode is over but
then we cut to duplicate working out in
the gym things are still tense between
her and Rex Spode after he found her in
the shower with the immortal he calls
her gross for going out with a guy who's
over 2,000 years old and she mentions
that if you add up all the time she and
her other duplicates have lived she's
probably the same age as the immortal
and he's likely the only other person
who has died as many times as she has
she just interesting logic of how one
person's separate traumas can all add up
together in the amalgamation to equal
another person's trauma and that's one
way they can connect with each other
again I'm probably just overthinking it
but I'm fascinated by this monster girl
who's even younger now since she's been
using her power so much tells rex that
he just doesn't get it and he says what
are you going to knock my teeth out
again this is a reference to her wailing
on him in season 1 when they were both
auditioning to be part of the Guardians
of the globe shape Smith comes in and
tries to act like a normal Earthling but
he has no idea how a treadmill works
since they obviously don't have these on
Mars Rudy tries to map his brain to
conquer the fear that he felt last fight
not realizing that fear is not the mind
killer PA trades fear is actually
something that we need fear is a
biological Instinct that helps us
survive he listens to till Unis spegel
Merry Pranks by
Strauss and meditates monster girl tells
him fear exists for a reason and he
shouldn't go down this road and he gets
up the courage to ask her out to a movie
Debbie goes to a spouses of superheroes
meeting at the community center and
hears Theo sharing about how much she
misses her partner after the meeting
Debbie texts Mark several of her texts
to him have gone unanswered good luck
today so proud of you did he have to
fight William for the best bed and then
bet the cafeteria food doesn't compare
to mine this is clearly making her feel
even more vulnerable and she types one
day in college and you're too big to
call me back but then followed by three
upside down smiley faces she deletes
that one and types call me when you have
a chance and then deletes that and types
I miss you before she sends it she runs
into Theo smoking by a cigar who invites
her out for a drink Debbie deletes a
text to Mark without sending it and
takes Theo up on his offer saying I
could use a drink she's been drinking
more and more since Nolan left and I
have to say despite with Theo's
apparently good intentions I just don't
think it's great for members of like a
depression support group to go right to
drinking drinks who might a judge but
for Debbie this is not a healthy step to
take Rudy tells monster girl that he's
never been to a movie mov since you know
he was floating in a tub of liquid and
couldn't move his whole life the movies
on the Marquee are midnight Slaughter
ritual feline Cobra's alloy Cog and
Senior Loop there are movie posters on
the building one that looks like an
homage to La fem Nikita and a Mr Mrs
Smith looking one and a vampire film and
a werewolf film they try to get in to
see midnight Slaughter but since it's
rated R the take a guy won't let them
out without a parent permission and they
do make a good point like how does a
parent sitting there make it any worse
or better remember monster girl is
around 25 now and Rudy is about 30 they
both just look like kids monster girl is
used to this though and pays a woman 10
bucks to say that she's their mom after
the movie monster girl makes Rudy eat a
burger Mart burger for the first time
and he comments on how unappetizing
looks calling back the date that Allan
and tella went on earlier monster girl
makes a joke about how Rudy used to only
eat food from his butt and he says that
that's not how it worked and this
totally reminded me of how America
Chavez asked doctor strange and Wong if
Spider-Man shot webs out of his butt and
Multiverse of Madness Rudy houses the
burger and fries and it's just fun to
see a wholesome normal date between a
girl who turns into a monster and a kid
who used to inhabit a consciousness of a
robot Debbie and Theo chat and bond at a
dive bar Theo drinks the same beer that
Eve created from the pine cones in her
house in episode 2 and Debbie is just
drinking something clear it's probably
Jin on ice with the lime no mixer for
her and she's to freak out when Theo
tells her this I wish I could tell you
it gets easier but Alana's been gone
nearly a year and I still reach across
the bed for her every morning Alana aka
the green ghost was a photographer and
member of the Guardians of the globe
that was killed by omn man when he
punched straight through her face in the
series premiere Theo calls him an alien
psychopath and Debbie excus herself to
go cry later Theo finds her in an alley
and she tearfully confesses that omn man
is her husband although to her he was
just Nolan Grayson and Theo is
unforgiving he tells her not to come
back to the group because it wouldn't be
a safe place and when Debbie says that
she didn't know what kind of man her
husband was he tells her coldly you
should have before leaving Debbie looks
up at the stars with just despondence in
her face and then walks down the middle
of the abandoned Street completely alone
the middle of a street doesn't care if a
car hits her Mark returns to his dorm
room and will instantly knows he had had
sex with Amber will confess is that he's
still messed up about what happened with
Rick we saw Rick get turned into a
partially lobotomized cyborg in season 1
Mark tells him that Cecil says he's been
doing better and should be released in
about a month so I guess he was still
being looked after at the global Defense
Agency for the past year there's a knock
at the door and Seance dog is there
asking for Mark but since seon dog is a
fictional character Mark immediately
goes into fight mode it turns out it's
just a bug creature looking for Mark's
help to save his Planet he appeared as
something Mark loved in order to disarm
him just like the alien did with jod
Foster in contact this alien identifies
himself as new from the planet thraxa in
the comics this is a planet where Nolan
escaped to after leaving Earth and comic
spoiler alert if you don't want to know
more skip to this time Nolan married
andessa axen and had a son Oliver with
her who goes on to become the superhero
kid omn manes understand that noza comes
in as a form of Mark's childhood toy
making me wonder if this is something
Nolan might have told him like a memory
that Nolan still had about his son
showing that there might still be a
Teran Soul somewhere in that
psychopath's mind noot claims immediate
showers destroying the planet and Mark
is their only hope Mark doesn't want to
go but will convinces him that he needs
to go and help we keep seeing the humans
close to Mark keeping him on a path of
being a hero and preventing him from
turning into his dad Debbie will Amber
they're all acting as Mark's conscience
reminding him what his responsibilities
are kind of like Uncle Ben and
Spider-Man Mark defies cil's wishes and
goes off with noot to thraxa which is a
gorgeous planet with these antenna
looking structures noot says that the
Monarch wants to meet Mark at once and
we hear this kind of beautiful Heavenly
music but there's even something creepy
in off about this music and we get the
big reveal drax's Monarch is actually
Mark's dad Nolan omn man who greets Mark
with an outstretched hand telling him
hello son it's been a while and we end
with the dolly zoom on Mark as he
responds dad and I love how the
animators actually made a dolly zoom in
animation normally this effect is
created practically by like zooming in
on a subject while you pull back on the
dolly or vice versa and here they had to
morph the dimensions of mark space in
animation to make it look narrow and
flat and frame to really underscore the
drama of this reveal so the words it's
been a while are the title of episode 4
and I cannot wait to see how Mark reacts
to seeing his dad again after all this
time the fact that he's still
manipulating Mark getting noot to appeal
to his sense of empathy to get him there
instead of telling him the truth just
doesn't give me confidence that he's
actually changed all that much click the
link in the description box to download
Dragon air check out the exclusive gift
codes to Redeem limited option gift
packs join D and D Legends and dragon
air support us by grabbing a shirt from
nerd riot. shop subscribe to all three
channels of the new rockstars Network
follow me on all socials at eaos Big
thanks to Gina AO for writing this
breakdown thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
bye